der walter ablinger ist mittlerweile 20
jahren im rollstuhl
wie durch ein arbeitsunfall in diese
situation kommen
in dieser situation hat man natürlich
nur zwei möglichkeiten entweder man
nimmt situation so an wie sie ist und
macht das beste draus oder man scheitert
an der gesamtsituation das
österreichische bundesheer ist
mittlerweile an einem punkt angekommen
wo auch schwächere aus unserer
gesellschaft gut integriert werden
wir sind kein schlechtes sein rad am
wagen sondern wir sind ein wichtiges rad
am wagen
ich bin mittlerweile paralympics-sieger
ich habe insgesamt drei olympia mit
allen fünf wm medaillen davon bin ich
einmal weltmeister waren
ich habe dreimal gesamtweltcup gewonnen
und bin 14 facher österreichischer
staatsmeister
wir machen im prinzip eigentlich nichts
anderes wie profisportler
wir können uns unseren fokus auf das
training legen die nötige regeneration
haben wir dabei wir haben eben als
soziale absicherung die können unseren
sport professionell ausüben
mir geht es darum dass sie diese
möglichkeiten habe für mein land und für
uns als gesellschaft zu zeigen dass man
trotz schwieriger situation auch
erfolgreich sein kann
jeder in sich hat schicksalsschläge zu
bewältigen jeder in sich möglichkeiten
gutes positives leben zu führen und in
jedem von uns steckt ein held